hi i'm ming nawen and i play fenik shand
kyoda
timur de morrison i play boba fett and
uh we are the cast of the book of boba
fett aka also we started off on the
mandalorian and he of course is the
legendary boba fett here we go
first what is your greatest strength and
the options are patience discipline
creativity honest problem solving or
leadership what's yours tim none of them
i'll push honesty
i was gonna push honesty you can't push
honesty you push something else oh
okay uh well it's definitely not
patience okay i'll say problem solving
how's that okay very good all right
which star wars character would you want
as your partner in crime we have jabba
the hutt boo
captain phasma
emperor palatine
general hux
in general grievous oh
count dooku oh
he was here i'm going with
count dooku i'm going with the top
emperor palpatine
sorry meant it should have been general
grievous but never mind if you were to
wield a lightsaber
what color would you want it to be
red purple green yellow blue or orange i
know what i'm gonna go
with green yeah i'll go with orange i
didn't like purple last time i saw that
purple one
i know
yeah that was the last thing i saw that
was not good for you i stopped watching
the movie
[Laughter]
there was nothing else to watch oh my
head had come off that's why what
creature would you travel across the
galaxy to steal
okay a pork a tauton an ewok a zealand a
yoda species or a wookie i'm going first
a yoda species i'm gonna go with an ewok
yeah i like those ewoks they were great
to work with
they were funny they were funny they
were funny and finally which of these
star wars movies do you consider the
best oh ye
that's tough the best a new hope the
empire strikes back return of the jedi
revenge of the sith the force awakens or
rogue one oh i took of the clones but
i'll go with rogue one
a new hope because that's what
started my whole star wars fandom
i'm finic shin
shhhh
that is such fake news no really yes
you're lying
no stop
seriously
you are someone who has trained and
worked hard to get where you are in life
hey that's in real life as well you keep
your friends close but your enemies
closer very good that is true that's so
funny i got darth maul darth maul hey
that's that red guy with the black paint
i know that's that's really bad
yeah
you know what my personality matches
with darth maul because uh i am loyal
obedient observant well that is true
fiercely loyal to the people who have
helped me someone who often wants to go
it alone yes yeah yeah yeah because i
feel like i could do it all by myself
your confidence is one of your greatest
strengths and i don't know about that i
try okay that's so cool okay that's
great that's enough looking in the
mirror
right there hi fennec
okay let's play another game now thank
you so much buzzfeed love this this was
fun buzzfeed and watch the book of boba
fett streaming on disney plus yes
you